hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well if we look at the
moral theories of the Stoics very
carefully and in particular activist
discourses we see that although stoicism
is in certain respects very different
than other paradigmatic examples virtue
ethics it really is a type of virtue
ethics and one of the things that that
means is that it's not only attentive to
you know rules about things or
individual cases it looks at the human
being in terms of their general sets of
responses to things and evaluates those
morally not just how they behave in one
given situation other types of ethics
tend to focus a bit more on giving rules
or guidelines for how to resolve
particular cases they place a great
emphasis on being able to make decisions
in particular situations and they tend
to be rather weak on this very important
element or rather dimension human moral
existence which is heaven Epictetus is
going to tell us quite a bit about this
in book two although there's going to be
other instances in other books where
bring it up as well and you notice I've
got this scheme up here the reason I put
that up there is because what it
illustrates for us is that you know the
Faculty of choice the pro-am race is
also translated as moral purpose which
is at the core of what a human being is
according to the stoic viewpoint the
Faculty of choice is able to make
choices which lead to actions at the
same time what actually structures the
fabric of the Faculty of choice how do
we decide whether a person's Faculty of
choice is well ordered or oriented or
whether it's all screwed up well a lot
of that depends on Kamath's whether our
habits are good habits or ban against
what we called virtues and what we call
vices now the habits by the way are
necessarily going to be moral as as
we're going to see sometimes the action
may bear upon or the choice may bear
upon another faculty right how do we use
say our faculty the music-making or to
use another example epictetus loves our
grammatical faculty our linguistic
faculties we would say right we are able
to direct all these other faculties by
using the Faculty of choice but they're
also structured by Hamlet's as we're
gonna see as we look at now when we
engage in a choice we will often already
feel ourselves steering towards one side
or steering towards another side and
part of them is the you know our
inclinations that are desires then you
know coming from things outside you know
saying hey why don't you do do this why
don't you do that
we don't know except angels and devils
on shoulders we may have all sorts of
other counselors and advisers but we
also tend to get steered by habits so
I'll use an example that epictetus
itself devotes quite a bit of attention
to and which I can speak from experience
about anger right anger from the stoic
respect
it's always going to be a bad thing and
we can talk not only about the emotion
of anger but we can talk about something
like a hat or a vice of anger and there
you know the Greeks actually had a
distinction they would talk about you
know working anger and then somebody
being ordered ethos being an angry
person and her askable person is how we
translated now my name is you know we
say somebody needs anger management
usually may only do that if they've done
something really bad ordered because
most people who are a regional Minotaur
recognize it but when we get into a
situation where there's a likelihood of
us getting angry because we see somebody
do something and we don't like it and we
feel that it's an insult to ourselves
and now our reasoning you know is going
into full gear or thinking text sob I
better do something to show him I'm not
going to put up with that and we start
to get angrier and angrier in a lot of
cases that's the habit that that's doing
the work there and the habit is not
strictly speaking making the choice for
us what it is doing is making the choice
a tougher one for us or rather it's
making it an easy choice to choose bad
thing is making a harder choice with
exert more effort to do the right thing
and epictetus would say it's look it's
still within our realm of responsibility
and we are also responsible for our
habits once we become aware of them and
by the way once we become aware of our
habits as important in moral life it's
usually because we're partly screwed up
with respect to them so we have some
some work to do now when we make a
choice we can either strengthen they
have it or reinforcing it you know
making it more and more part of who we
are or we can weaken and eventually we
can replace certain habits with other
habits one of the teachers of epic
tennis is a great example of this polo
ball was
sometimes criticized because he was a
guy who when he was young and apparently
he you know he liked to drink a lot and
chase the chase women and then you know
he eventually trained himself to being a
different kind of guy and you know
everyone saw it such a continent such a
temperate guy and whole moment say well
yeah you know me now but that's because
I had to struggle against these these
habits and then overcome them so what
does that Katinas tell us specifically
there's two portions of the text where
he goes into this quick tip and in the
chapter 9 of two he says that actions
strengthened or destroyed particular
faculties in the person so you know if
you want to be a good musician you
actually need to do some practicing you
know this is something that anybody
who's ever tried learning instrument
that was quite well you can't just get
yourself in front of a drum kit or pick
up a clarinet or pick up a guitar and
start you know playing smoking on the
water or if you want smoke on the water
is pretty easy that's what most people
learn it right away you have to practice
you have to put the time and the word
likewise you know in order to learn how
to speak well that takes some practice
even be able to be able to use the
language so it's to write effectively
grammar right this is what they're
calling it here that requires I have it
that's a faculty that's a power of the
human being that has to be developed you
want to learn how to become a farmer
there's a lot of things you actually
need to learn like pulling weeds pulling
weeds sounds really easy
get your yourself out there and start
doing it for a couple hours and take a
look at what your patch looks like and
what the patch of somebody who actually
knows what they're doing looks like you
see all these little weed tops still
sticking out can you get down in there
and pull with the right amount of
pressure and you know figure out what
kind of plant you're working with well
that's a man
having certain habits right so the
actions are going to strengthen or
destroy particular faculties of a person
these include the moral faculty the
Faculty of choice then this includes our
our Faculty of Reason which is really
the same thing if we don't use it
rightly we're gonna screw it up
and there isn't a single part of us that
can't get screwed up by misuse so this
is why he says the Philosopher's tell us
we don't just need learning my thesis or
my thing it's a burden there but also
practice malaise literally paying
attention to what you're doing it you
know you practice by doing something in
a deliberate way over and over again in
a discipline the Greek word for that is
s casus the word that we get ascetic
from this will often involve making
choices that you know deprive you of
something that you kind of want at the
time right so if you want to be a great
athlete but you have to cut up a lot of
things from your life you can't be out
there partying all the time there's not
a lot of good athletes become bad
athletes right if you want to become a
great musician you know when when all
the groupies are coming backstage you
probably need to say you know I really
need to spend a little bit of time
practicing sorry I can't can't hang out
with you past ten o'clock it hurts
something along those lines I don't know
about that because I'm not in the music
industry but I imagine it would be like
that no those are important things to
keep in mind in 2:18 he tells us very
explicitly it's not just the disciplines
that are strengthened by it by by
actions it is the habits themselves that
are generated or destroyed by the
actions and the you know these are
consequences beyond the situation I
think that a lot of people don't realize
in part because it's more convenient not
to realize this then when we're making a
choice we're not just making
choice for right now we're not just
making a choice in this particular
situation where we have responsibility
just for how we're acting at that point
we're making a choice that incorporates
the past as part of what the the aspect
of habit is the PAS coming into the
present and you're making a choice for
the future the kinds of persons we're
going to be whether it's gonna be easier
or harder for us to do the right thing
or to do the wrong thing the next time
that we're in a similar situation and so
epictetus is going to tell us that we
were actually worse off after we give in
to our desires for bad things for things
that are actually not good for us or
give in to what we would he calls
appearances right you know appearances
that get in our way so he says in this
way without a doubt the infirmities of
our mind and character sprang up once
you can see the desire for money if
reason be applied to bring it to a
realization of the evil if you can get a
good glimpse on what's going on there
both the passion is still then your
governing principle is restored to its
original Authority but if you don't
apply a remedy your government in
principle does not refer to its previous
condition the Faculty of choice the pro
I race is the governing principle is not
in a completely neutral State it's
getting better or it's getting worse as
a whole you know the whole person was
oriented around this so the person is
becoming better or worse so he says I'm
being aroused again by the corresponding
external oppressions it bursts into the
flame of desire more quickly than it did
before
if this happens over and over again the
next stage is that kind of callousness
results and the infirmity strengthens
the Animus the greed a greedy person
becomes in a certain way blind to the
effects of what is happening to them
likewise he talks about anger
he says certain immigrants and wheels
are left behind on the mind and a muscle
man a race
perfectly the next time you skirt death
on the old scars he has wheels no longer
but wounds so it's there for you wish
not to be hot-tempered do not feed your
habit sending for it nothing on which it
can grow very tough to do trust me I
thought that because I had been trying
to put this into effect don't allow that
habit to begin to be active once it's
already established don't feed it don't
give it
sustenance instead pay attention to
something else he says the first step
keep quiet and count the days on which
you have not been angry I used to be
angry every day after that every other
day then every third and then every
fourth day if you go as much as 30 days
without a fit of anger sacrifice to God
for the hamon is at first weakened and
then utterly destroyed this is what we
can say about every single habit that
either stands in our way or helps us
along we don't just want to get rid of
bad habits by the way we want to produce
good habits so then it becomes easier
and easier and easier for us to choose
what is genuinely good for us and
genuinely good for the rest of the world